hello everyone how are you guys doing
hope you guys are having a wonderful day
and today we are here with a money
making video I don't make a lot of these
however I do kind of want to make more
in the here nerd near by future I guess
um I have a lot of like small techniques
to make money that I could definitely
share with you guys and I feel like you
know you know more ways that make money
you have the better I'm gonna delete my
private check anyone saying alright so a
lot of money making videos have two to
three I don't I don't know I feel like
it's just not necessary once decently
enough and I like to keep it short to
the point just give you guys something
to do and game if you guys wanna make
money um the only requirements for this
is a little bit of starting cash and the
completion of one small favor so if
you're a decently high level 2 count
you'll have one small favor done if not
just tell me what level you guys are
below and I'll make some money making
guides for those levels and nonetheless
let's get right on into it so basically
as I was saying you're going to need to
have done one small favor and have a
certain herb lower level let me check
that out for you guys I don't I don't
want to just leave you guys like that
alright so the potion is made during one
small favor so you need 18 at least to
be able to make it so I'm going to tell
you guys what it is in his gut fix
restores this is something used commonly
by pecans as you can see right here you
can either put them in threes or you can
decant them however I'm just going to go
ahead and speed through me making one of
these this is without mouse keys or
anything like that so you can definitely
up how much you'd be able to make but
I'm going to show you guys what you have
to do so first you're gonna want to grab
14 alright I'll show you guys exactly
what you want so hard Landers you're
going to need one of those for each
potion you're going to need a mare until
you're going to need two guam's a empty
cup and a bowl of hot water this all can
be bought I can fresh take it for you
guys real quick this all can be bought
as you can see here for around the price
of I think it's more around 700 GP and
you will need another Guam's so like 714
GP so if you do 714 times 28 let me do
that real quick alright now you do 14 at
a time so 714 will do 7 14 times 14 that
will be a total of pretty much 10k on
the dot to do this and then I will speed
up the clip showing me how or showing
you guys how I do this alright so now
I'm going to show you
how to do the CEO and to want to grab 14
bowls of hot water 14 empty cups and
just click away all right so to make the
guthix restore as I was saying you're
gonna need to guam leaves amer until a
harry lander empty cup full of hot water
and you just all you have to do is put
that in there and then use each one of
these herbs on the little cup you get
actually a decent amount of vert blower
experience so I think you get around 60
for each potion you make you can do like
that personally I like to take out 14 of
these at a time then 14 of these put
them all in take out 14 Guam's put them
all in 14 more put them all in then 14
14 and then you're done so I'm going to
go ahead and fast-forward that and show
you guys how long it takes me to do that
you
I accidentally just cut off that clip so
there we go finished making fourteen of
these I didn't in a minute 30 however
earlier when my clicks were just a
little bit better and I had been making
these for a little bit I was able to do
it in a minute 20 and that was without
any mouse keys at all or any like I'm
not really good at clicking I would
imagine you get this method down to
about a minute to a minute 10 somewhere
in there so as we can see here if we
press check all of them you can expect
to get around 34 K I don't think the 28
K price range is necessarily correct so
I'm going to go over here and decant
these because they're more commonly sold
as four doses rather than threes so as
you can see we're going to then price
check all of these and see if we can get
anymore for that as you can see there we
have 34 K - the 10 K that it actually
took us to make all of these so with
that being said we have then 25 K is how
much all of this is worth and I was able
to make that in a minute and 10 to 20
seconds so we will just say on average
you should be able to get about a minute
15 to be able to make 25 K so whenever
you do the math on that can do 48
inventories an hour and you multiply
that times your 25 k profit you can
expect to make 1.2 mil an hour doing
death extras' tours the problem with
these are I don't
I mean if too many people do them it's
not good but I don't think this video
blow up that much so you guys should be
pretty good just whatever you do this
method what you're going to want to do
is do not insta sell a bulk of 1k guthix
restores for just sell them slowly at a
time just find out what the buy or sell
prices and sell them at that
so with that being said hope this guy
hope this video was informative that is
just a little bit of me doing it
I could do more I could do like a
thousand and show you guys that that's
legitimately what you can make but as
you saw right there that is what you can
make so I don't feel there's any need to
do any of that other than to tell you
guys what you can do in game to make a
little bit more cash so nonetheless with
that being said hope you guys have a
wonderful day if you guys enjoyed the
video make sure to hit that like button
you guys want to see more money making
guides worthless to Wall Street my
merging series anything like that feel
free hit the sub button if there's
anything I can improve upon
tell me about it down below in the
comments or just you know general
comments about anything feel free to
leave them down there if you guys want
to join my clan chat in-game not really
my
but a clan chatted chillin oh seven
helpers is the name nonetheless with
that being said I hope you guys have a
wonderful day and